sur la couverture de son roman petite
rue des bouchers paru chez de fallois et
qui ressemble fort à un livre de
souvenirs
voici georges moustaki à bruxelles en
1955 il a 21 ans le jeune joseph must
est qui qui a quitté sa famille grec
d'alexandrie pour l'europe et pour
gagner sa vie
ils tapent sur des pianos bientôt il
composera la fameuse chanson milord pour
edith piaf avec marguerite monnot
mais pour l'heure les temps sont durs et
merveilleux de bruxelles et de la
belgique si accueillante moustaki alors
ne connaît que les heures sombres
les familiers des boîtes où il joue la
faune habituelle des musiciens des
filles de joie des noctambules et des
journalistes
on ne s'étonnera pas que georges
moustaki regarde cn et lointaine avec
émotion et tendresse et qu'il se
souvienne précisément de jocelyn de
paloma de ramsès
ce n'est que beaucoup plus tard que
moustaki découvrir à bruxelles deux
jours avec ses tramways les éventaires à
gaufres reparti pour paris
il y mène la carrière glorieuse que l'on
sait écrivant pour salvador et pour mon
temps pour barbara la dame brune et pour
reggiani ma liberté son propre [ __ ]
fait un malheur en 1969 mais moustaki
n'a jamais oublié bruxelles il y revient
le temps de se lier